no I'm growing up in a very English
household food was something that we
loved but my mother never knew how to
make my mother to this day makes the
best tea and coffee I've ever had in my
life but she really can't make anything
else she grew up in Africa and she never
was taught how to cook by her mother who
was in fact a fantastic cook so I never
learned from my mother how to cook I
actually learned from Julia Child and at
the age of seven and I remember this
it's one of those pristine moments I
remember chasing something and thinking
this really is not very good and I bet I
could make it better and at the time the
French chef was on relentlessly on PBS
and you know you only had 13 channels at
that time and I watched it over and over
and over again and I really loved Julia
Child she influenced me so much in so
many ways her silliness her love of food
the relaxed quality about food not
taking it very seriously and also the
whole point about food being something
that connects each other and it's
something that you can do together so I
literally learned how to cook from the
age of seven and and that's one of the
reasons why I find it so important to
teach children how to cook and the
importance of teaching children how to
eat well and actually I'm coming up with
a cookbook about that very subject in a
couple months